[Music]
[Music]
oh
hello didn't see you there i'm dr mays
university of latino phd we got
ourselves a new trailer for the highly
anticipated
breath of the wild 2 which just like my
phd
is amazing the first few weeks and
months after a discovery like this are
often crucial to the zelda theory
community
as it is around this time that everybody
will be combing through the footage
reversing it slowing it down flipping it
upside down
all in the hopes that they might be the
first to discover a hidden clue
in this new trailer and that's amazing
right i mean
zelda's hip again everybody's talking
and discussing
they are indeed exciting times
but it's also during this time that a
lot of theories become
widely popular but then later it turns
out that these
don't exactly hold up remember that
whole seo gannon debacle
the problem is that by the time these
ideas have been put to the test by
others
they've been seen by so many people that
they keep popping up in discussions
long after they've been either
challenged or flat out disproven
i mean i still get comments about the
whole seal ganon thing on my videos
to this day which makes me not happy
that's why for the new trailer for
breath while 2 i'll be covering some
claims and findings which
i feel should be at least challenged
with counter evidence or
debunked if possible now i gotta be
clear about this
this is all in good fun i don't wanna be
that guy
that zelda elitist who likes to shame
people for their ideas
i actually enjoy that there's a
discussion going on and i highly
encourage people to put their ideas out
there
i just want to give my take on the
matter and see if i can convince people
to think differently
after all that's how we get closer to
the truth
today we'll be talking about one
specific subject that being
music but before we kick things off
proper science cannot be conducted
without
funding after all who's gonna pay for
this fancy magnifying glass
so first a word from our sponsor
do you enjoy watching things on the
internet oh my god me too
let's be best friends well if you do
some of you might be familiar with a
screen like
this one that's right my friend you are
being punished for being born in the
wrong country
if you crave to get around this crime
against humanity enjoy some added
security and or keep those nintendo
ninjas off your back then consider
giving atlas
vpn a try atlas vpn which currently has
more than
5 million users worldwide is a tool that
encrypts your data and hides your
virtual location
i have no idea how this works but that's
why i make youtube videos what i do know
is that when you connect to a vpn server
your device is given a new ip and dns
address kind of like a secret passport
ie you will be the ninja around here
another great feature is the data breach
monitor by inserting your email address
the tool scans the internet to see if it
ended up in any recorded data breaches
or data dumps that include
emails names passwords or other
sensitive information
enabling notifications ensures that you
are aware of such incidents and gives
you a heads up to change your passwords
before anyone has a chance to steal your
accounts
an added bonus is that atlas vpn works
on any device so you can have only one
account for the whole family to use
so even you non-pc master race casuals
can use it
it also provides a 30-day money-back
guarantee for all subscription purchases
so say for instance you want to watch a
british show like top gear which is only
available on netflix uk
you simply open up atlas connect to a uk
server and gaze at expensive cars that
you and i will likely
never own currently atlas vpn is running
a big discount on their three-year deal
for just 1.39 per month so if you're
interested don't hesitate to check it
out by clicking the link in the video
description down below as this deal
won't last for long
go to atlas vpn monster maze to grab
your 1.39 per month deal
again that's atlas vpn monster maze
and now back to our regular program
[Music]
alright let's talk music more
specifically
hidden tracks or references people claim
to hear in the new trailer
especially when played in reverse
whenever a new trailer drops playing it
in reverse to see if there's any secret
illuminati messages to be heard seems to
be one of the first things people do
and it's only natural nintendo has on
certain occasions been hiding little
secrets and references in their music
before
ones which can only be heard when the
track is either played in reverse
like the way they expertly incorporated
zelda's lullaby in the ballad of the
goddess from skyward sword or the song's
notes are spaced out or change
rhythmically to a degree that only those
who listen closely will pick up on it
then there's a few more obvious ones
which aren't necessarily hidden but are
still a nice callback to a previous game
a good example being the track that
plays in and around hyrule castle which
contains sections from zelda's lullaby
the tune
ganondorf plays on his organ in ocarina
of time and the original zelda theme all
neatly wrapped into one song
but the thing that all these musical
easter eggs have in common
is that they are all undeniably there
the notes and or chord progressions
are one for one and don't require the
use of your imagination
which brings us to the recent claims
about breath 202's music
we'll start with the one that received
the most attention coming in at 268k
views at the time of writing this script
a user named
taco made a video claiming that when
reversing the track that plays when hiro
castle was seen rising
it matches a song called the events of
100 years ago which plays during the
cutscene where king rome talks about the
backstory of calamity
ganon and the events which led up to the
destruction of hyrule
this video is also a main contributor to
the reason why people believe that the
game will feature time travel
but is this really a solid piece of
evidence or just our brains making
connections that aren't there
simply because there's a similarity well
as you might have guessed
the latter is most likely the case in
fact after looking into it a bit deeper
i'm not even worried about being wrong
anymore
to demonstrate i've recreated both
tracks as presented in taco's video so
keep in mind
the section from the trailer music is
the reversed version
as it is only then when it's supposed to
match the other song
obviously there's a noticeable
difference in speed between the two
original tracks the one from 100 years
ago
is significantly slower than the one
heard in the trailer
but this doesn't disprove a connection
since as we've demonstrated before
the speed and rhythm are sometimes
purposely changed either to match the
song they are hidden in
or to mask the song in a clever way as
long as the note progression and scale
match it could be considered a fair
piece of evidence
for the sake of this comparison i've
programmed the two songs so they play at
the exact same speed
this makes it easier to hear both the
similarities and the differences
so are there any similarities well yes
there definitely are
for starters each of the two tracks
starts with an f both consist of a total
of six
notes which even move up and down the
scale in the same way three rising notes
then it drops back down
and we get another three rising notes
unfortunately for taco this is also
where the similarities
end the actual scale used in the tracks
are not comparable the events from 100
years ago
is a bit more conventional going from an
f to an a
sharp to a d sharp then dropping down to
a g sharp
d and then g the trailer music uses a
lot of semitones which gives it that
ominous vibe
it goes from f to b to c then a
d-sharp and finally e overlaying the two
tracks shows just how different they
really are if this was supposed to be a
reference
it would be a terrible one and playing
the songs at the same time reveals just
how incompatible they really are with
one another
it bears repeating that just because the
notes move similarly on their respective
scale
doesn't mean that they are connected in
any way the pattern of three climbing
notes dropping back down and then
another
three rising notes is quite a common
thing to do in music
as an example a recent song from age of
calamity called a quiet moment
also opens up with a similar pattern
so no i do not believe that there's any
correlation between these two songs
if there was there wouldn't be so many
conflicting notes
now let's cover a theory which didn't
reach as wide of an audience as the one
from taco but still managed to garner an
impressive 20k
views this one is by ace monkey who
suggests that breathful 2's music hides
another
more iconic song from the series namely
the song of time
and similar to taco uses it as leverage
to prove that breath of the wild 2 will
feature
time travel the big difference between
this finding and the one we covered
previously is that here
the notes are not the problem at least
they're not conflicting
the problem is the implication let's
quickly listen to what ace monkey has to
say
let's hear the first four notes of the
sequel steam
we have the notes e c d and a
all right now let's play it in reverse
[Music]
did you guys hear it so right away i
have to ask
ace dude bro dude why are you
ignoring the double a at the end you
acknowledge it when you play the song
forward
but in reverse you suddenly ignore it
and only play the a
[Music]
once
i get that it's about a theme but i have
to wonder if you left it out because
it's not relevant or because
it wouldn't sound as convincing with the
x-ray a included
second if this was supposed to be a
secret reference to the song of time
which can only be heard when playing the
music backwards
why would they not only include a small
incomplete version of the song but also
what is perhaps the least recognizable
part of it
the first six notes of the song is the
part that everybody knows
[Music]
you know the part that you have to play
like a thousand times over the course of
the game
the section referred to here is the tail
end of the song
and is even missing that last d at the
end to round off the song properly
in the trailer music it instead goes
back to an e and then moves on to a b
beyond that point so that's also where
the similarities in the note progression
end altogether i might not be a music
teacher but
as someone who's played in various bands
for years and has written dozens of
songs during my quote unquote
musical career i can tell you from first
hand experience that it's extremely easy
to write a song with the exact same
notes or chord progressions
unintentionally and without even
realizing it not to mention
all of ocarina of time in majora's
mask's recognizable music was all
written within the confines of the same
five notes available on the ocarina
there are many songs that feature the
exact same notes just played in a
different order and timing
examples being zelda's lullaby and epona
song which featured the same three notes
and the song of healing is literally the
notes from sarya song just played in
reverse
i have to appeal to your sense of logic
to say that just because there's one
specific section in the song that has a
couple and
i repeat a very select couple of
matching notes which only form an
incomplete less recognizable part of the
song to then conclude
ah song of time hence time travel
is stretching it quite a bit wouldn't
you agree but you know what
don't take it from me i'm just a guy who
likes to rock out in a spare time
i might have an awesome phd but i don't
have a degree in music theory
so to make absolutely sure that i'm not
missing anything i've asked my good
friend
tim damon for his opinion not only does
he teach
music and has composed countless of his
own renditions of famous zelda tracks
and tracks from other franchises such as
mario but he also plays like a zillion
different instruments
so let's see what he has to say on the
matter hey there my name is timdemon
i'm not a music theory expert either but
i used to be a music
teacher in a different life i've spent
the last five years
studying the breath of the wild
soundtrack here on youtube and have made
dozens of arrangements of zelda music
in all kinds of styles since then i
think it's really cool that people
listen to zelda music in such an active
and analytical way
all that reversing stuff up is getting
on my nerves though
i'm just kidding or am i in general
people hear a lot of similarities in
zelda music
for example i can hear a lot of
similarities between
kobrak forest the dark world from a link
to the past
and song of storms let me play it for
you
[Music]
that's fun but korok forest sheer flying
relaxed
um the dark world heroic and slightly
well dark and song of storms with its
bonkers windmill action have little in
common thematically
so are they referencing each other
but did you also know that these
three songs are also similar to steam
gardens from mario odyssey
mario's in the zelda universe confirmed
what this illustrates is that musical
similarities crop up
all over the place in this case because
of a specific composer's musical
signature
steam gardens dark world and song of
storms are all written by koji kondo for
example
kondo's musical style became part of the
zelda musical style
so yasuwaki iwata wrote korok forest
in a condo-like style no story
connections
no clear references just musical
signature
however sometimes musical similarities
can also be
purely coincidental for instance
did you know that the flintstones are
part of the zelda canon
fred flintstone is ganondorf confirmed
so when looking for musical callbacks
and references we have to be mindful of
the role that musical style
surrounding thematics and coincidence
play in the tunes we recognize
else we get a lot of false positives
with this in mind
let's look at our two examples
all right so what are the steps needed
to relate 100 years ago to the ending of
the second breath of the wild 2 trailer
1. it has to be played in reverse 2 we
have to be a little creative with the
notes being played
and 3 we've got to plug bananas in our
ears
as monster mazes pointed out the
similarities are the melodic shape
which is very generic just like our
flintstone example
and that both sound a little weird
that's not much to base a connection on
but let's gather some more info before
we draw any conclusions let's analyze
both motifs and try to figure out why
they sound
like they sound and if that steers us
further into the
yay musical reference direction or the
name musical reference direction spoiler
its name 100 years ago alternates two
different shapes
the stacked fourths that are a hallmark
of the breath of the wild sound
and a different more crunchy sound using
a tritone interval
this interval was historically called
the devil's
interval because it sounds a bit
unstable and crunchy
not surprising then that the tritone is
often used in zelda games in
relationship to antagonists
so 100 years ago may have a subtle
connection to ganon
that's sort of in favor of the 100 years
ago equals breath of the wild 2
theory now let's look at the new trailer
motif
[Music]
yep this is tritone town all right the
tune alternates tritone intervals
with semitones the smallest interval you
can usually make in western music
and an interval that like the tritone is
also connected to friction
so this fragment is a double dose of
extra ganon
extra crunchy
of course the theory was that this
should be played in reverse so let's do
that and see if we can find similarities
this doesn't really work for me but do
you know what this does remind me of
the calamity ganon boss fight music
walking around in semitones and ending
on a tritone
the connection between the calamity gun
and boss fight music and 100 years ago
is clear as day from multiple
standpoints thematically both are about
ganon
the same ganon actually and musically
there's an obvious similarity as well
so in my opinion 100 years ago musically
has
too little in common with the breath of
the wild to trailer music
and thematically only has a small
connection there's a much stronger
connection between breath of the wild 2
and the calamity ganon boss fight music
which leads me to believe that that's
what the composers were referring to
here
the notes in the song of time and the
breath of the wild 2 fragment
that was referred to earlier are
seemingly the same
when played in reverse i might add but
rhythmically it's very different
and a note has been omitted if i play
the
segment in reverse exactly like it is
with the correct rhythm and missing note
this is what it would sound like
[Music]
that doesn't really sound like the song
of time anymore now does it make sense
thematically
the only connection that i think is
reasonable is the physics rewinding
power that link seems to have
with boulders running back up the hill
and drops of water falling upward to
where they came from
would that be enough for the composers
to put in a song of time reference
maybe but for me it's not a sufficiently
strong enough connection to disregard
the obvious musical differences looking
at the way the notes have to be reversed
and stretched and omitted at the
uncertain thematic connection
and at the way musical reference and
zelda music usually are quite clear once
discovered
i'm inclined to join monster maze in his
conclusion
so do we have a false positive once
again the short answer is
yes the long answer is yeah
so there you have it folks there's
absolutely nothing hidden in breath of
the wild 2's music
well actually there is an obvious
musical reference in the breath of the
wild 2 trailer
in plain sight i might add oh do tell
i found a direct musical connection
between the main themes of breath of the
wild and its sequel
it's even got some cool possible
series-wide implications
i've got an entire video about it over
on my own channel
definitely don't want to steal your
thunder so if you haven't already
go check out tim's discovery in general
i highly recommend checking out his
channel not only has he been kind enough
to permit the use of his music to enrich
some of my videos but he also offers
tutorials
free sheet music and even more goodies
for his patreon supporters
so to all the musicians aspiring
musicians or just
video game music enthusiasts among you
tim's channel is definitely the place to
be
thanks for chiming in on this one tim
thanks for having me
so as you can see it's
[Music]
so as you can see it's very easy to hear
similarities in music
but unless you either have experience
with the more technical side of music or
if the references are undeniable and
clear as day
99 of the time it's just your brain
trying to make connections that aren't
there
if for example you're going into a track
with the presumption that this game will
take place at least partially during the
events of 10
000 years ago chances are your brain is
going to focus on the similarities while
ignoring the differences
and while i'm on a rambo anyway if this
is indeed supposed to hint at the story
event from 10 000 years ago
why would they use this song
specifically this song is played during
the cutscene where king rome explains
what happened 100 years ago
not 10 000. sure it shows the tapestry
from 10
000 years ago at the very beginning but
that's only a small part of it
i mean the song is literally called the
events of 100 years ago
funnily enough there is actually a song
called ancient folklore which is played
when impa explains the legend from 10
000 years ago but i guess that song
didn't fit with the trailer music did it
now
now before calling it a wrap i will
mention one final thing regarding the
music
just in case someone brings it up in the
comments those weird reversed vocals we
hear during this scene in the trailer
are still the exact same melody we hear
in the first trailer
just sped up significantly and you'll be
pleased to know that there are still
no references to other zelda tracks in
here either back in 2020 i even joined
nintendo black crisis in a video over on
his channel which covers misconceptions
about the first breath to a2 trailer and
here we also touch upon this specific
track so as opposed to explaining it
here all over again i encourage you to
watch that video instead there are even
more videos which make comparisons
between the trailer music and music from
other games
but these didn't get enough traction for
me to devote an entire section to it
i want to reiterate that i have no ill
will against
any of the people who came up with the
ideas covered here nor
any other ideas floating around i am not
like that
at all as a quick example despite the
fact that the link is dead and majora's
mask theory has been proven wrong
i still greatly respect matpat for his
creative thinking
it was a fun and exciting theory and
just because it ended up not being true
doesn't mean it deserves mockery or hate
gear towards him
zelda theories are just that theories
i'm quite certain that at least ninety
percent of the stuff i've predicted or
suggested about breathtak
ii will end up being wrong also it
definitely wouldn't be the first time
i think this person is a woman the eye
shadow and the face structure definitely
seems to hint in that direction so you
see them
zelda theories really are a bit like
science most of the time you're wrong or
it's very hard to prove something
indefinitely
unless nintendo themselves decide to
chime in which they rarely do
but every once in a while after
countless of incorrect predictions and
false assumptions there could be that
one theory which does lead to a
breakthrough so
please keep those ideas coming no theory
is stupid unless it's the tetraforce
thank you for watching recently we got
ourselves a new trailer for the breath
of the [ __ ]
a special shout out goes to tim damon
for joining me in this video and of
course my amazing patreons
and channel members please give a warm
welcome to
matt johnson emmy menk jared whedon
lepetron 3000 as well as farmy for
rejoining
your awesomeness cannot be understated
as always
thank you so much for deeming me worthy
of your support and
that is all for now this is dawn signing
off and
have a good one
[Music]
you